filipino president rodrigo duterte gears
up for a faceoff with china it's his
fifth visit there at a time when he
faces pressure back home to raise the
problem of Beijing's military expansion
in the South China Sea
even before it began it promised to be a
feisty affair Duterte threatened to
cancel the trip if he couldn't discuss
the contested waters the Philippines
like others in the region rejects
China's claim to the area China wants to
control virtually the entire sea which
is a critical shipping route rich in
fish and oil and gas reserves in recent
years Beijing has stepped up naval
patrols and even constructed man-made
islands they're worrying neighbors and
in 2016 an international tribunal in The
Hague ruled that China was in the wrong
China ignored the ruling in the
Philippines critics have pounced on to
tear teh for being seen to turn a blind
eye to China's development in return for
trade but when a Chinese vessel rammed a
fishing boat in June leaving 22 Filipino
fishermen dead
Duterte could not ignore public anger
any longer joining us is Richard Haidari
an author of the rise of Duterte and
also more recently the Indo Pacific
Trump China and the new struggle for
global mastery so very well-placed
explain some things to us tell us
Richard to what extent is domestic
pressure influencing to tear ties
actions on this trip yeah I mean the
president's very popular in terms of his
overall approval ratings but on the
issue of foreign policy and his policy
towards China that's where we see a lot
of problem there's a pushback from his
own top generals including his defense
secretary and national security adviser
of openly raised concerns about
potential espionage with the influx of
Chinese illegal workers and citizens and
the Philippines but more importantly
intrusion of Chinese warship into
Philippine waters at the same time the
greater public wants him to raise the
2016 arbitral tribunal case against
China and in fact more than 90 percent
of Filipinos wanted to take back some of
the land features the China wrest
control of
the Philippines in recent years
particularly this Scarborough Shoal so
he's taking a lot of it at home and in
that context is going back to China and
trying to save this wrapper small which
is very controversial at home now I want
to talk about China's belt and Road
initiative is investment and
infrastructure scheme to what extent
does the Philippines benefit from the
belt and Road initiative I guess what
I'm wondering is is what is President Xi
Jingping
offering Duterte that's kind of making
him open to giving up a little bit of
filipino sovereignty over the area of
the South China Sea right
well the fact of the matter is that
president has tried to justify his
controversial you know obsequious policy
towards China
through two different justifications one
is that he's been arguing that if you're
nice to China they're gonna invest big
in the Philippines and back in October
2016
China offered more than 20 billion
dollars twenty four billion dollars of
investments now the problem is that
three years into the datura
administration not much is moving on
that front in terms of China's public
infrastructure investment the
Philippines in fact as far as I'm
concerned there is ZERO Chinese
infrastructure project which has cleared
the preliminary phases and most of these
projects even in their initial phases in
the bidding procedure are facing
controversies over potential death trap
or potential violation of the Philippine
laws so the doTERRA test fallback option
is to say well let's be nice to China
other ones will have war with them which
is also are getting a lot of traction at
home and that is why he's taking a lot
of heat and suddenly saying you know
what I'm gonna raise arbitration award
and confront China mm-hmm and so this
South China Sea issue is a regional
concern put this in context what are the
neighboring countries watching out for
when it comes to this duterte and she
meeting yeah I mean the fact of the
matter is that the Philippines is
occupying important role because it's
the country coordinator for ASEAN in
China and currently overseeing the
negotiations of a code of conduct that
is supposed to govern the relationship
of competing claimant states there in
the South China Sea
and president duterte in a lot of ways
also the most prominent leader in
Southeast Asia today quite a
controversial one but prominent one so
they're gonna watch where the Philippine
goes because just few years ago the
Philippines was the most aggressively
anti-china country which took China to
international court now you have
president artists into a completely
different show so people are wondering
words the Philippines is going and what
is also the implication in terms of US
alliances in the region because the
Philippines is a key US ally and if the
Philippines holds on to its rapper small
under the theater and pushes back
against us
that'd be also difficult for the United
States to project power in the region
and put the Chinese you know keep the
China at bay so that's where the
Philippine scene Richard hey Darien
thank you